all right I'm Dave Rubin and this is one
more thing on the Rubin report so we
talked a lot of topics this week we did
politics we did porn pretty much
everything in between what I was
thinking what I like about doing this
show is I want to bring people that come
from different worlds and bring them
together and see if we can come up with
something that's that's cool and get a
good vibe gone and I think we did that
here so you guys I think actually have
something very much in common that
someone wouldn't think about so Lance
you were in in sync huge boyband and
then it went away can we say went away
it was it was gone it's time we're still
long term hiatus we'll say and and then
you made a very personal decision to
come out it has given you a new life and
a new career etc etc and Janke for you
you were in mainstream news and then
that also went on a bit of a hiatus
really by your choice but wrangling with
the powers that be so to speak and I
think this idea is fascinating that
people get to a point in life where they
have to do something profoundly personal
to fix their lives and so the question
that I'm gonna ask both of you guys is
where do you remember when that moment
happened that you knew you had to do
something that I know for myself that
saved my life but that's something that
really changed your life do you remember
that absolute moment well I mean it goes
back to when I publicly came out I knew
at that moment the reaction that that
got was where I needed to be in life I
love doing music I love being an
entertainer but what gave me the reason
to keep going was knowing that I could
affect people's lives in a positive way
and that I was I'm so happy that I'm
alive in this whole transition of the
civil rights you know movement right
here in America because I'm just I'm
proud to be a part of that and I'm glad
that I'm putting that position to help
out as much as I can
Jake what about for you what was the
moment that you said all right the
corporate route of this doesn't fulfill
what I need to do I gotta go I'm gonna
go build my own freakin Network which
I'm a mad
some people around you said you're not
yeah well I got that plenty of time so
you know we'd been building the network
for a while and I was we were so
building it while I was at MSNBC etc but
there was that moment when I had to make
a decision on whether to stay at MSNBC
and keep things quiet or come out I
guess in a sense I which I hadn't
thought of that way and say look this is
what happens in reality behind the
curtain right and I remember being in my
living room you know and pacing up and
down up and down trying to decide there
were so many different factors and I was
been honest about this one of them of
course was money I'd never made that
much money before when you go on TV you
get a much bigger salary and they had
offered me a huge deal
in order to go to the weekends and stay
quiet about how things work on the other
hand I I knew something that I thought
my god if I could share that with the
audience if it was somebody else's story
I would do it in a second but it's my
story and I have it where the head of
MSNBC has told me you know the
establishment doesn't like your tone and
you need you know you need to bring it
down and you need to play ball and you
need you know and so I was torn about it
there was you know there's New York
there's LA there's my family and I
thought well why did I get into this in
the first place and the whole point of
doing this was to be honest with the
audience and if you lose that point no
matter how much the money or anything
else you could never get it back right
and and so I I wanted to be true to what
we were doing so I decided to turn the
money down and come out and publicly
tell the story about how in corporate
media there is a you have to toe the
line and you have to play Democrat and
Republican games and not challenge the
government too much and I think I owed
it to the audience to tell them that
yeah well that's why I wanted to bring
you guys together because I think it's
fascinating that people have a very
personal thing that actually in almost
every case transcends their personal
lives and then goes out and helps other
people so my last question for tonight
is where do you think you would be if
you had not made that choice you know
I'd probably be singing within sync
right now still
who knows uh I you know I I love what I
do but I mean I have such a weird time
you know ten years ago was such an odd
time in history of sports a gay you know
rights went and and who knows what would
have happened if I would have came out
ten years ago in the band maybe it would
have made things go a little faster I
don't know or it could have gone the
other way and just really tanked and and
ruin my whole life and I'd be you know
five hundred pounds at home eating my
Cheetos and just depressed but I sense
no regrets about the zero regrets zero
regrets jQuery to be you know sometimes
I look at the commercials that MSNBC
does and I think well they would have
done one for me you know I was gonna
have a weekend show and with like Chris
Hayes did most harris-perry
and godly looks so nice you could write
write write exactly and and I hear about
who's dating who there and I think like
oh my god like they got the money they
got the girls they got the commercials
etc so there's a little part of me that
of course feels like ah that would have
been nice right now and that's how they
seduce you
right but of course overall I think this
the whole point of building this entire
career over 17 18 years was to be true
to yourself so you know I couldn't have
it all that pacing was for nothing
because in the end you have to be who
you are and it was just a process to get
to find out who I really am
with me like what if I just decided to
play the straight card the rest of my
life marry a famous actress and you know
be this it couple in Hollywood but
living a lie I mean that would have been
easy route and that's a route many
people are doing today but that would be
selling out and that would not be you
know being true to myself be true to
yourself that's it thanks guys
I remind you guys that the official
outfitter of the Reuben report is
bonobos go to bonobos calm use code TRR
to zero and get yourself this fancy
shirt